One of the keys to Apple is Apple's an incredibly collaborative company.
Do you know how many committees we have at Apple?
No.
Zero, we have no committees.
No committees.
We are organized like a start-up.
One person's in charge of iPhone OS software.
One person's in charge of Mac hardware.
One person's in charge of iPhone hardware engineering.
Another person's in charge of worldwide marketing.
Another person's in charge of operations.
We're organized like a start-up.
We're the biggest start-up on the planet.
And we all meet for three hours once a week and we talk about everything we're doing,...
...the whole business.
And there's tremendous teamwork at the top of the company...
...which filters down to tremendous teamwork throughout the company.
And teamwork is dependent on trusting the other folks...
...to come through with their part without watching them all the time...
...but trusting that they're gonna come through with their parts.
And that's what we do really well.
And we're great at figuring out how to divide things up into these great teams that we have...
...and all work on the same thing, touch bases frequently...
...and bring it all together into a product.
We do that really well.
And so, what I do all day is meet with teams of people...
...and work on ideas and solve problems...
...to make new products, to make new marketing programs, whatever it is.
And are people willing to tell you you're wrong?
Yeah.
I mean, other than snarky journalists; I mean, people that work with you.
No, we have wonderful arguments.
And do you win them all?
Oh no, I wish I did!
Now see, you can't.
If you want to hire great people and have them stay working for you,...
...you have to let them make a lot of decisions and you have to...
...be run by ideas, not hierarchy.
The best ideas have to win.
Otherwise, good people don't stay.
But you must be more than a facilitator who runs meetings; you obviously contribute...
....your own idea.
I contribute ideas, sure!
Why would I be there if I didn't?